just run
you he will be
Sam raymie hand-picked you to direct
Evil Dead rice
um what were some words of wisdom he
gave or
you know advice making this film yeah I
think the first thing you did was gauge
my interest and then I went off and
thought about the story that I wanted to
write the screenplay that I wanted to
write
um and then during that process as I was
thinking we had many discussions and I
do remember Sam saying to me look
there's two important things here you've
got to use the book and make sure the
dead eyes are scary and in the nicest
possible way I was like of course
because the book is very dear to me and
making sure that those dead eyes were
terrifying was of massive importance but
he showed me a hell of a lot of support
and and backing for what my vision was
for the movie now the Evil Dead
franchise is known for three things
um Gore humor and Ash Williams uh which
of these elements were the most
important for you when making Evil Dead
rice well Ash Williams was never going
to really be in this movie because it
was definitely a departure and I think
Bruce Campbell has publicly said that
you know he kind of hung up his chainsaw
so that wasn't one I have to kind of
think about you know I think that I
wanted to make a very scary horror movie
and the gore part of that so I kind of
thought about character first but then
when it came to those elements you've
listed I thought I called the gore the
horror I thought about those elements as
much as I possibly could but I also
wanted there to be little little pieces
of light in the story like little
release valves where there's little bits
of kind of levity and humor and kind of
funny lines that break the tension ever
so slightly so it was actually by
blending those two things that was the
really important thing was getting that
blend just right thank you um so I just
want to talk a little bit more about
these elements that you Incorporated in
your movie starting with the Gora like
people lost their minds when they saw
the cheese grater in the trailer oh and
that's just like the tip of the iceberg
because there were like a lot of
everyday home objects used in the gore
how did these ideas come about they they
were something I would have thought
about naturally because I based the
story in the home but I also wrote this
screenplay
um during the first wave of covet when
everybody around the world was locked in
their home so I was in my little
apartment in Dublin writing the
screenplay on my bed
um with this unseen Force outside the
door uh in in terms of this virus that
was in the world so I had a lot of time
to look around
um the confines of my home and to feel a
little bit trapped and to freak out a
little bit and start to identify the
objects that I wanted to to plant in the
story and then to pay off later on in
these kind of increasingly crazy
horrific but entertaining ways
thank you um another moments in the film
that made me chuckle and the ones that
made me go like yo what the [__] how did
you
how did you strike the balance between
the horror and the comedy was it a
challenge or did it come naturally it's
always a challenge because it's about
getting the balance right and getting
the tone right but I think the comedic
elements are the lighter elements really
come from character because the people
feel real and real people even in very
dark times often crack a joke or say
something that's inappropriate or
whatever it kind of might be so I kind
of wanted the the the the lighter parts
or the levity to kind of come out of the
circumstances and come out of the people
with the pressure that they're put under
so in a way by putting pressure on them
those little moments kind of start to
happen but also I had the control of
what the dead I'd say what you know
possessed mom Ellie gets to say as well
and I had a lot of fun in creating some
of her dialogue and lines which I think
really entertain people I'm hoping to
see some of her Dialogue on t-shirts
very soon because I think
alrighty thank you so much thank you
very much take care
[Music]
what movie will be